the explosion of medical knowledge and
technology has led to a dramatic
increase in specialization of medical
care
providers and sites one aspect of this
is that care for complex problems has
become increasingly regionalized
one downside of this centralization is
that the relative ability
to properly treat some classes of
patients at non-centers has declined
a prime example of this specialization
is neonatal care
newborn medicine has become highly
specialized
one problem is that many small hospitals
which are perfectly well qualified to
deliver babies
are not set up to properly care for
seriously ill infants
this has led to a dramatic increase in
inter-hospital transport
unfortunately sick babies can decline
astonishingly quickly
the goal of our system is to provide
continuous
real-time medical telepresence that will
allow experts at the best
neonatal care facilities to participate
in the care of babies
both while the baby is at the hospital
in which it was born
and should transport be necessary during
that critical period of time when the
baby is between hospitals
we believe the deployment of the system
will lead to better patient outcomes
improved care while at the community
hospital
improve care during transport and
better preparation at the receiving
hospital so that
urgent care can be provided immediately
upon arrival
our system has three components an
instrumented environment in which the
baby can be cared for and transported
a communication subsystem that provides
a bi-directional
real-time video link between regional
neonatal care centers
community hospitals and the vehicles
used to transport babies
and an application that facilitates
collaboration
amongst those in charge of caring for
the infant
the most technologically challenging
component of the system
to build was the communication subsystem
it is built
on top of the commercial cellular data
networks
using the cellular data networks poses a
number of challenges
these networks provide limited bandwidth
they suffer from a high
packet loss rate and they are
notoriously unstable
our solution is to multiplex the streams
over multiple cellular channels and
exploit
carrier diversity here's a video of
one of our test runs the first thing we
see is the transport team loading the
isolette into the truck
here's a physician from children's
hospital sitting at the application that
runs at the hospital
there are three cameras two focused in
the baby and ones on the vital signs
monitor
the doctors can switch back and forth
among these cameras
there is unfortunately a slight delay
when the camera is changed
to allow the buffers to refill so that
the video provided can
continue to be smooth the doctor is also
visible on the user interface in the
ambulance
which allows the doctor to demonstrate
procedures
that he or she might wish the team in
the ambulance to follow
here's a video from a different test run
this baby is approximately two months
old
and considerably larger than those
babies we expect to be transported
notice however that the motion as
perceived by the doctor
is quite normal and the resolution
perfectly adequate for diagnostic
purposes
frequently the physicians will observe
something
that they wish to refer to another
physician
they can save video typically what the
doctor will do
is want to say video of something he or
she has previously seen
so the doctor is allowed to save the
previous minute
or two minutes or five minutes of video
video is saved on a web server at the
hospital
which can then be accessed by anyone
with access
to the hospital's network it's also
possible to zoom
in or out doctors are likely to do this
to inspect
wounds or skin lesions perhaps the eyes
things of that nature one of the more
popular features amongst the doctors
is the ability to take a snapshot and
email that snapshot to a collaborator
for a second opinion in our tests we
discovered
that our system was considerably more
reliable
than cellular telephone communications
we also discovered
that the level of noise in the ambulance
particularly when the respirator was on
was sufficiently high that oral
communication could be a challenge
and the doctors and the transport team
began to rely increasingly
on the instant messenger facility for
communications
in conjunction with our collaborators at
boston's children's hospital
we've done several simulated transport
tests
the physicians found the system easy to
use and postulated that it now provides
all the facilities they need to make an
impact on patient care
premature births account for 75 percent
of neonatal deaths
and 50 of neurological disorders
despite these dire numbers it is
important to remember that even for
very premature babies excellent outcomes
are possible with the proper care
our work should help more babies receive
care
that will lead to excellent outcomes